bevor das Video losgeht habe ich leider
eine schlechte Nachricht für euch der
aktuelle Pasta poesia Drop ist
ausverkauft deshalb vielen Dank dafür
aber ihr könnt bereits vorbestellen dann
bekommt ihr nicht nur frisches
pestogenovese mit metzemanike packen wir
mit Pomodoro ist sals sondern auch echte
Spaghetti Carbonara mit guanchale zu
euch nach Hause gieefaht und das ohne
saah und jetzt viel Spaß mit dem Video
Freunde herzlich willkommen zum
teuersten Frühstück meines Lebens ich
stehe hier vor dem Grand Hotel Schloss
behsberg ein sehr sehr bekanntes Hotel
bei uns in der Region wir sind ungefähr
eine halbe Stunde von Köln hier schlafen
staatsoberholbt das Stars also die Creme
della Creme hat hier schon residiert und
wir werden heute zu Gast sein allerdings
nur für ein Frühstück denn hier gibt es
die Möglichkeit jeden Sonntag die Woche
einen Champagner Frühstück zu buchen das
haben wir getan für
142 € der eric ist heute leider krank
deshalb habe ich eine noch bezauberndere
Begleitung Lari ist heute mit dabei
meine Freundin darf mich begleiten
normalerweise wäre das hier so schade
dass Du krank bist Eric nein schreib mal
gute Besserung Eric in die Kommentare
und jetzt schauen wir uns dieses
unglaubliche Hotel einfach mal an wir
werden hier schon direkt freundlich zum
Platz geführt so Freunde hier ist unser
Platz da ist Lari meine Begleitung man
sitzt alleine schon total bequem ne also
so gepolsterte Stühle so Freunde jetzt
sitzen wir hier an unserem Platz und es
ist ab dem ersten Moment wirklich sehr
sehr schön also nein so diese
holzvertefenung an den Wänden die
Speisekarte lässt wirklich einiges
erwarten und ab dem ersten Moment wo wir
reingekommen sind wir haben direkt zum
Bahn glüwein angeboten bekommen wurden
vom Personal zu unserem Platz geführt
und man guckt sich im Raum und denkt
sich okay ich bin auf jeden Fall der
Ärmste hier also wirk die Leute sind
glaub dumm reicht gönne ich ihn aber wir
gönnen uns heute dieses köstliche
Frühstück ich meine diese ganzen
Räumlichkeiten hier sind crazy die sind
fast jeden Sonntag ausgebucht und es ist
einfach riesig hier dementsprechend kann
man erwarten dass es sehr sehr gut und
sehr besonders sein wird wir schauen mal
gemeinsam in die Karte da geht es auch
schon los das erste Glas Rosé Champagner
wird eingeschenkt dann auf dich Lari
UI der schmeckt wirklich sehr gut neftig
berig das Konzept ist wie folgt wir
kriegen Getränke zum Platz gebracht
Kaffee Champagner wie auch immer im
Eingangsbereich gibt es verschiedene
Stationen quasi ein Buffet mit einmal
der tranchierstation da gibt es eine
ganze Ente von der man dann quasi was
abgeschnitten bekommt Bergische Waffe
ist klingt wirklich vielversprechend
aber bevor wir das hier alles durchlesen
gucken wir uns das mal gemeinsam an der
erste Schluck Schallert schon richtig
den Kopf merkst ja also der wird auf
jeden Fall noch ankommen wir wollten
natürlich auch all in gehen also die
Option mit Rosé Champagner kostet 142 €
die mit normalen weißen Champagner
kostet2 aber ich wollte das tollste
Frühstück meines Lebens erleben das war
be verosuckt soll wir mal aufstehen
besser was essen bevor wir zu betrunken
werden
ALR das ist wirklich krass ne also wir
gucken uns mal um wir haben hier frische
Austern direkt auslegen wir haben
wirklich eine krasse Vielfalt von von
von
christlichkeiten muss erstmal eine
Orientierung verschaffen oh hier WD sich
schon ordentlich bedient der Lachs ist
scheinbar sehr beliebt sicher dir mal
was ab Bo hier gibt's dann jetzt frische
trüffelnocki hier hinten geht's schon
eher so in die hererzhafte
mittagsrichtung also haben wir die
branchierstation später h wird's die
Ente geben also ich glaube der Plan muss
sein man frühstückt erstmal um dann
direkt danach zu Mittag zu essen ich
glaub das ist so die Strategie mit der
man hier rangehen das sieht aber auch
gut aus alles ne also crazy ich ma mal
einen schönen Teller fertig und dann
sage ich euch was ich
habe
lassen wir einfach mal ganz kurz so
diese Atmosphäre auf uns wirken man
sitzt an einem Tisch mit einer
wunderschönen Stoff Tischdecke frischen
Blumen Silberbesteck champagn glläser
und man kann sich wirklich alles was man
sich nur vorstellen kann am Buffet
wollen es ist nicht gigantisch aber es
ist einfach sehr sehr gut kuratiert also
du hast wirklich die edlen Dinge weil
das erwartet man natürlich auch bei dem
Preis den man hier zeaht ich habe auch
meinem Teller jetzt z.B Austern ich habe
Lachs ich habe ein hummersalat ein
bisschen wild dann noch frische backwarn
und vor allem Honig direkt aus der warbe
das ist crazy also bei mir ist es ein
bisschen wir irgendein Salat Lachs und
rötchen mit Honig Senfsoße eine austa
das weiß ich nicht mititello tonato und
so ein Stückchen Laugenstange und ein
Joghurt okay probieren wir mal Danke wo
fange ich jetzt an ich glaube ich starte
mal mit dem hummersalat kriegt man hier
mit so ein bisschen gepuffter hürse glau
ich habe ich auch noch nicht oft
gegessen h Salat Lari schmiert sich hier
in Brötchen sind die einfach Dinge im
Leben Leute aber dafür mit Lachs und
Honigs Senfsoße also es fällt für mich
gerade relativ schwer so diese ganze
Erfahrung so ein bisschen zu überschauen
zu überblicken weil zum einen ist es so
dass die Auswahl so groß ist dass es
irgendwie so eine ganz neue Welt ist die
man betritt es ist wirklich so Top 1%
shit was wir hier machen auf jeden Fall
es ist einfach eine krasse krasse
Auswahl die wir haben also der
humersalat den ich jetzt schon probiert
habe super lecker und ja man kann Gefühl
auch richtig viel entdecken
man will ja natürlich wenn man wenn man
herkommt will man auch die besonderen
Sachen essen ne weil ich meine du kannst
so viel Hummer essen wie du willst und
so viel schin trinken wie du willst für
122 142 € kann man schon mal wieder
überlegen ne also wenn man sich mal
Ehren mus könen will aber glaubst du
wirklich dass hier nur super die
Superreichen sind nein es ist jetzt
schon finde ich auch so ein Erlebnis ein
was man absolut verschenken kann und das
was ganz Besonderes ist also man fühlt
sich besonders wenn man hier ist so in
diesen tollen Räumlichkeiten mit dem
Service mit K was man hier haben kann
das ist schon echt schön also ist ein
schönes Geschenk aber inm der ganzen
Leute von denen man ausgeht dass sie
wirklich super reich sind FHT man sich
dann doch eher wie so ein kleiner kurz
ja ja richtig vund im Prinzip ist mir
auchgefallen wir haben drei
Möglichkeiten zu essen wir haben jetzt
gerade das Frühstück wo es vorwiegen
kalte Speisen gibt gleich haben wir die
Möglichkeit auch herzhaft warm zu essen
quasi zu Mittag also mit den
trüffelnycki mit den tren von der Ente
und danach gibt's noch Desserts deshalb
beenden wir jetzt das Frühstück den
frühstückspart mit frischen
zimtbrötchen mit dem ich mir so ein
bisschen honigwbe nehme und also man
kann sich hier wirklich sehr sehr gut
gehen lassen es ist noch so ein kleines
Fragezeichen da ob sich das Ganze
wirklich lohnt also ich bin gespannt ob
ob das warme Essen noch überzeugt bei
142 € dafür kannst du halt auch in das
eine oder andere Sterne Restaurant gehen
und ien zehn Gänge menüen das bleibt
spannend gucken wir mal was es gleich
gibt weißt du was mir so ein bisschen
auffällt bei uns wir reden übelst leise
ja man füstert die ganze Zeit so ein
bisschen ne man will einfach so gerade
weil so Filmen und so man fühlt sich so
ein bisschen wie ein Fremdkörper aber
auch ohne Kamera würde ich glaube ich
jetzt hier nicht so ganz frei und offen
reden man hat so das Gefühl man ist so
in so einer High Society wo man so ein
bisschen mitspielen muss ja und man darf
bloß nicht auf der Reihe tanzen weil
sonst fät das so fällt halt so sehr auf
ich meine ich bin alleine froh dass wir
uns alle was mit Kragen angezogen haben
und so nicht irgende so casual
hergekommen sind weil Leute laufen hier
ir im Anzug rum und tragen Krawatte und
so es ist schon es ist eine andere Welt
und insofern bin ich sehr froh auf jeden
Fall dass wir das Video drehen weil ich
glaube das Einblick in diese
außergewöhnliche Welt so den kriegt man
nicht alle Tage das ist auf jeden Fall
auch für mich besonders und ich denke
ihr werdet auch Interesse daran haben
aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das hier
jetzt gerade so einem normalen
Sonntagsbrunch mit Freunden in dem Kaffe
in der Inst wo man so paar Pancakes
bestellt ein Bagel und so ob ich das
wirklich vorziehen würde aber ich bin
jetzt schon froh um die Erfahrung also
ich glaube wenn man einmal die
Möglichkeit hat was zu machen sollte man
es machen schauen wir jetzt mal was es
zum Mittagessen gibt ich sag schon
Mittagessen was weit warmes gibt was ich
krass finde ich habe eislat und tfmch
bestellt und in solchen etablisss
schafft es niemand eine vernunftige
Hafermilch zu benutzen und ich verstehe
es einfach nicht weil es ist ja nicht
schwer sich eine barissa haer zu kaufen
aber was war ein gerade probiert sich
Macha zu bestellen gibt's nichtatte zu
bestellen gibt's nichtte kte mit
Hafermilch kommt aber die Hafermilch ist
ganz eigenartig ich glaube auch dass so
in diesen Kreisen so du du du
partizipierst nicht an solchen Trends
man hat so echt das Gefühl dass in
diesen räumigkeiten hier so ein bisschen
die Zeit stehen bleibt ich glaube das
das Frühstück was es heute gibt das
gab's auch schon vor 10 Jahren vor 20
Jahren und das wird auch in 10 Jahren in
20 Jahren geben das ist einfach zeitlose
Klassik so ein bisschen Luxus so wir
sind jetzt bei der Hauptspeise
angekommen also beim herzhaften Essen
eine Gänsekeule spzle da so bisschen
dunkle Bratensoße Rotkohl da drüben
haben wir noch Trüffel jokiari ist schon
mittend drin ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
B schon gut
angesättigt müsste das jetzt schon nicht
mehr essen sondern so man will halt noch
was davon haben dass man hier ist
eigentlich echt schon satt von dem
ersten kelleren wir jetzt mal die
Gänsekeule an eine Keule sollte ja
sowieso saftig sein aber schauen wir mal
wie saftig sie ist ja sieht gut aus das
ist auch jetzt keine keine Sterne Küche
die man erwarten dar man steht da vorne
das wird quasi frisch für einen
aufgeschnitten tschiert
angerichtet hab mir auch angeboten dass
ich noch mal meinen Teller unter die
Wärmelampe mache dass der auch warm
bleibt und so weiter und soofort wir
alles frisch zubereitet es ist schon
wirklich sehr sehr besonders aber am
Ende des Tages steht halt auch dieses
riesige Preisschild drüber ne das ist
schon echt verrückt sehr lecker also
qualitativ ist das alles Oberklasse wir
haben gefrühstückt sehr extravant
gefrühstückt und jetzt können wir uns so
ein Premium Mittagessen ist schon schon
Spal man muss wirklich sagen dass diese
zieinhalb Stunden hier s jetzt knapp Z
Stunden hier die Vergehen Flug es geht
so schnell dadurch dass du die ganze
Zeit bedient wirst am Essen best dich
unterhältst dass man schon fast Gefahr
läuft g alles zu probieren weil man zu
entspannt herangeht aber ich werde heute
auch nicht alles probieren also ein
kleines Dessert kann ich dannach
vielleicht noch essen aber dann bin ich
auch im L ich glaub es wird aber echt so
eine Erfahrung sein die muss ich erstmal
sacken lassen also holen wir uns erstmal
Dessert so ich habe mir ein kleines
Dessert geholt es gab wirklich eine
gigantische Auswahl man hätte von einem
riesigen Schokobrunnen hätte man sich
Schokofrüchte machen können es gab
frische Waffeln verschiedene Desserts
Patisserie und ich habe mich einfach
entschieden für dieses kleine
schokotatlet mit weißer Schokolade
dunkler Schokolade und Passionsfrucht
weil ich einfach nicht mehr kann also
ihr habt gesehen was ich gegessen habe
dadurch dass wir lange gesessen geredet
das alles genossen haben hat man gar
nicht so viel gegessen also glaub die
wenig Leute kommen hierher so mit diesem
Gedanken okay ich esse jetzt alles auf
sondern man ist schon relativ moderat
ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel aber ich
habe so feine schöne Dinge heute
gegessen probieren wir noch mal dieses
Törtchen hier gar nicht so leicht zu
essen merke ich gerade let try ober ist
der Klasse auf jeden Fall we ganz
interessant finde ist dass ich nur drei
Gläser Champagner getrunken habe das
eine zur Begrüßung dann haben die einmal
nachgefülllt dann haben wir noch mal den
weißen probiert ich habe jetzt gar nicht
so viel gegessen und ich habe auch gar
nicht so viel getrunken ich glaub das
sollte ich alles in meine Überlegung
einbeziehen aber eine Sache kann ich
schon mal sagen wenn ich noch mal die
Gelegenheit habe hierherzukommen ich
würde natürlich wiederkomm ist aber
würde ich noch mal bezahlen wir sehen
uns ganz in Ruhe wieder im Studio so
jetzt sind ein paar Tage vergangen und
mich haben ganz viele Leute gefragt wie
war eigentlich dieses teure Frühstück
also von meinen Freunden und ich war
immer ja mit geteilten Gefühlen unterw
wegs weil klar das ist cool in diesen
schönen Räumen zu sitzen teure Dinge zu
essen aber ich ganz persönlich habe mich
an diesem Tag glaube ich irgendwie fehl
am Platz gefühlt auch wegen der Kamera
die natürlich vor uns war am Ende des
Tages muss man auch immer Abwegen was
kann man mit 142 € machen kulinarisch
und da stehen z.B auch Sachen wie ein
gängemenü im Sternerestaurant offen
deshalb es ist eine Erfahrung um die ich
sehr dankbar bin mit Kamera würde ich
glaube ich nicht noch mal dorthin
vielleicht privat noch mal irgendwann
ganz so bald wahrscheinlich nicht ich
hoffe trotzdem dass ihr Spaß hat ich
glaube das waren sehr exklusive einwicke
die wir dort gewinnen durften falls euch
gefallen hat lasst gerne ein Like da wir
sehen uns beim nächsten Video wieder bis
dahin ciao ciao ich hoffe das Video hat
Euch gefallen nicht vergessen
pastafisier.de abchecken und das ist
rich schm